مشاهدينا الى الخبر العاجل حيث افاده
مراسل الجزيره بان غاره الاسرائيليه
تنتسدف موقعا للمقاومه الفلسطينيه وسط قطع
غزه معنا من غزه مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت
المزيد من المعلومات حول هذه الغرب
اسرائيليه او عده غارات سلسله من الغارات
الاسرائيليه شنتها الطائرات الحربيه
وطائرات الاستطلاع كذلك على موقع للمقاومه
في مخيم المغازي في وسط قطاع غزه هذه
الطائرات الحربيه لازالت تحلق في سماء
القطاع بحسب شهود العيان والعديد من
المصادر في تلك المنطقه في وسط قطاع غزه
همم الطائرات الاستطلاع بدات هذه الغارات
على هذا الموقع التابع لكتائب القسام
الجناح العسكري لحركه حماس وهو موقع
تدريبي همم كثير من المواقع المنتشره في
انحاء قطاع غزه قصفت الطائرات الاستطلاع
هذا الموقع بصاروخين ومن ثم قامت الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه بشان اكثر من 10
صواريخ على هذا الموقع مما تسبب باضرار
جسيمه في الموقع والمنطقه المحيطه بالكامل
في هذا موقع لازالت الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه تحلق في سماء القطاع وقد
شاهدنا قبل قليل على ما يبدو اطلاق نار من
المقاومه الفلسطينيه باتجاه هذه الطائرات
الحربيه وتحدثت المصادر ايضا ان المقاومه
استخدمت مضادات ارضيه لتصدي للطائرات
الحربيه التي تحلق في سماء القطاع واعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي انه بدا
بقصف قطاع غزه ردا على كما يقول اطلاق
صاروخين من القطاع هذه ليله امس في وقت
متاخر من ليله امس باتجاه مدينه عسقلان في
جنوب اسرائيل وبالتالي همم كما كنا نتوقع
خلال ان نشرات الماضيه فان الجيش
الاسرائيلي همم يعني قصف قطع غزه وحتى
الان هذا القصر يمكن وصفه بانه قصف محدود
ويمكن همم
يتسع اذا المقاومه على هذا القصف وبالتالي
وسع الجيش الاسرائيلي من عملياته في قطاع
غزه لكن حتى الان المشهد هو قصف اسرائيلي
على احد مواقع المقاومه وهذا القصف حتى
الان باكثر من 10 صواريخ من الطائرات
الحربيه
في سياق المشهد ابتداء من الضفه الغربيه
وكذلك في انعكست على قطاع غزه بدات صباح
اليوم عندما اقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي مخيم
جنين بالضفه الغربيه ونفذ مجزره كما وصفت
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في هذا المخيم وادت
الى سقوط عدد من الشهداء وقالت المقاومه
والفصائل الفلسطينيه بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
همم اغتال عدد من قاده المقاومه في مخيم
جنين وبالتالي هددت الفصائل الفلسطينيه
همم اطلاق يعني همم ترك وتنفيذ عمليات ضد
الجيش الاسرائيلي وان المقاومه لن تصمت
على هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي في الضفه
الغربيه والذي بدا
وتصاعد منذ تشكيل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الجديده التي تقول الفصائل الفلسطينيه
انها الاكثر تطرفا في الحكومات
الاسرائيليه همم المتلاحقه وبعد ذلك
كاطلقت اطلقت من قطاع غزه صواريخ باتجاه
ال- بلدات الاسرائيليه القريبه من قطاع
غزه وبالتحديد الى مدينه عسقلان جنوب
القطار جنوب اسرائيل
وقالت وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي ان منظومه
القبه الحديديه همم استطاعت التصدي لهذه
الصواريخ ودون وقوع اضرار او اصابات في
صفوف الاسرائيليين بعد ذلك بدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي بتنفيذ عمليه
قصف في قطاع غزه وقصف حتى الان هذا الموقع
في مخيم المغازي وسط القطاع وحتى الان لم
يتبين طبيعه الاضرار التي همم حدثت جراء
هذا القصف قوات الدفاع المدني وايضا همم
الاسعافات توجهت الى تلك المنطقه لكن
القصف عنيف وحتى الان لم يجري اخلاء او
تبين حادث همم الاضرار في هذا الموقع
شكرا لك